I'm going to grow up physically I
can do a massage and a riverside solo at this rate I don't
know what to do next
Detective sounds interesting but as far as I've heard it's mostly cheating investigation
I'm
a psychic, but
I'm afraid there are times when I can't control my powers.
I thought you might be the same as me, but
if you try to look at it, you'll see ghosts.
When I was young, I used to worry a
lot This guy looks at me with hopeful eyes If he's
seriously ill, he's a
rare inhabitant of a fantasy world
Let's treat him appropriately and let him go home
You know, because he has supernatural powers  It doesn't change the fact
that you're still a human being.You can walk fast and study.You have a strong body odor.My psychic powers are just one of my characteristics
.
Well, the essence of charm is humanness Be a good guy That's all
, can
I come back to
talk to you again?
Healing can be done with spirits Tomorrow
, I will teach him how to use the power of love in his time
[music]
At that time, I had a longing for that boy